you are watching cold kitchen TV for
those of you are short on time this
video is time coded so you can skip to
the topic you want in the description
below hey welcome to another episode of
cold fusion TV - gogo here
the internet something that was once
created to further the chances of the
United States of America surviving after
a catastrophic Soviet nuclear attack has
now become much larger much more
influential and more integral in
developed society than anything that has
ever come before the Internet has been
around since 1978 and the public only
gained access in 1991 as with everything
there's been a few key first moments
that would lead to the Internet as we
know today but what were they and what
were the stories behind the individuals
and moments that will become the first
steps in an incredible time for human
history in this video you'll learn
something and you'll have a bit of fun
along the way
we'll go through the history of the
internet looking at all the key moments
that change the world
here are 14 of them 1971 number 14
the first email the very first email was
sent by ray Tomlinson to himself in 1971
here's a quote from him in an interview
the test messages were entirely
forgettable most likely the first
message was QWERTY year or something
similar the funny thing was he wrote the
program for email in his own time and
nobody at his company really cared about
it
ray also pioneered the use of the @ sign
for the e mail 1990 number thirteen the
first website it was late in 1990 and
Tim berners-lee was working at CERN
Laboratories he wanted to make the
internet easier to use at the time he
had to literally be an expert in
computer commands just to work the
Internet
he wanted to link information together
and let users browse at will by
themselves what he had in mind was the
World Wide Web well it was 1989 and the
internet already existed and that you
could send email but there was no
websites filled those no HTTP HTML there
was no space or things you could click
through and it began because I was
frustrated it didn't exist I imagined a
system where you could just kick from
one to the other and that was so
compelling that I decided that I wanted
to build it and on the 20th of December
1990 the first web page was put up and
you're looking at it right now for the
first time the internet was within reach
of the average person everybody could
use it now the first page was simply
just a little bit of a guide as to what
the World Wide Web was and how to use it
the original page no longer exists but a
later copy from 1992 can be found at
this web address here's a fun fact as it
turns out the world wide web was built
on the next computer and it was actually
Steve Jobs who found it next during his
time away from Apple after being fired
in 1985 so Steve Jobs hadn't been fired
we may not have the Internet as we know
it today it's amazing how things link
together when you dig through history
1992 number 12
what was the first picture uploaded on
the web again it was Tim berners-lee and
this time was for a bit of fun in 1992
some of Tim's fellow employers at CERN
formed a parody band in 1990 they were
called the horrible sir nets or the
horrible sir nets in English one day Tim
just asked for a few scam photos of the
girls parody group he said it was just
to publish them on some sort of
information system that he'd just
invented called the World Wide Web
they didn't really think much of it and
they handed over the photos and little
did they know that it was going to
become a historic moment the very first
picture on the Internet
1994 number 11 the first search engine
although internet search engines had
been around even before the World Wide
Web
they were very limited in nature and
usually only contained a few page titles
the first full text web search engine
like the ones we have today was have a
guess you probably haven't even heard of
it it was called web crawler and I was
launched back in 1994 it wasn't until
three and a half years later when Google
arrived on the scene after this web
crawler pretty much faded into obscurity
number 10 the very first block
in 1994 five years before the turn blog
was even coined justin hall was doing
just that
justin's web-based diary was called
justin's links from the underground and
it went online in 1994 it offered an
early guide to the world wide web but
drifted into personal territory over
time the new york times magazine
referred to him as the founding father
of personal blogging
it wasn't until 1997 that the term web
blog was coined and this was later just
shortened into the word blog 1995 number
9 the first book purchased on Amazon on
April 3rd of 1995 John Wade right was
working a very early web joint venture
between Apple and IBM on this day he was
given a beta invite to a fledgling
company called Amazon and they were
trying to sell books over the fledgling
internet the first book was Douglas
Hofstadter's fluid concepts and creative
analogies computer models of the
fundamental mechanisms of thoughts it
sounds like such an interesting read I
think I might go out and get it right
now but maybe not but anyway that was a
piece of history and that was the first
Amazon book ever purchased number 8 the
first item sold on eBay eBay was
initially called auction web auction web
was founded in San Jose California
September 3rd 1995 by opre own media the
first item sold on eBay was a broken
laser pointer for $14.83 in 1995 when
Peary found out that someone had
actually bought his broken laser pointer
online he was quite perplexed and went
on to ask the man if he actually knew
that the laser pointer was broken and
the buyers response was quite odd he
said he collected broken laser pointers
and with that that was the very first
purchase on ebay 1996 number 7
the first mobile phone with internet
access the first mobile phone with
Internet connectivity was of Nokia 9000
communicator it was launched in Finland
back in 1996 but unfortunately the
actual cost of accessing Internet was so
high that it was actually quite
unsustainable
it wasn't until 1999 that iMode was
launched in Japan this was considered
the birth of mobile phone internet
services and today the impact of the
marriage between the mobile phone and
the Internet has gotten so large that
people say it's changing society in a
negative fashion there's no way you can
blame Nokia though 1999 number six the
world's first internet celebrity before
PewDiePie Rebecca Black jenna Marbles
Smosh Chocolate Rain
the dramatic chipmunk or keyboard cat
there was one guy who was in before it
was mainstream mejia Calgary from Turkey
anyone under 20 probably would be
scratching their heads this guy was the
original internet celebrity in 1999 his
web site a kisi org established him as
the first person to achieve celebrity
status solely through the internet his
web site was full of broken English and
happy snaps but 2000 Bill Gates was said
to be one of his fans mahir ended up in
the Guinness Book of Records for the
most visits to a personal home page with
an estimated 12 million hits some say
that he was the main inspiration for the
Borat movie in 2006 2003 number 5 the
first words ever said on skype the first
words said on skype were not in English
but in Estonian in April 2003 the words
were uttered by a member of the
development team and I guess he could
take a wild guess as to what they were
the English translation was hello can
you hear me
I guess that's only fitting for Scott's
first words Skype should have really
just been called can you hear me
2004 number four so the first person on
Facebook was actually ID number for the
first three Facebook accounts we use for
testing and you can guess who ID number
four was it was of course Mark
Zuckerberg the first non founder to join
Facebook was our a her sit sorry if I
butchered that name he is now studying
in Israel to become a robot after array
there are 1.3 billion monthly users to
follow so he started something 2005
number three the very first youtube
video the first youtube video was posted
by jared karim at San Diego Zoo it was
uploaded on April 23rd 2005 and has been
watched only 14 million times today keep
in mind at this time when they posted
the video they had no idea that YouTube
would have more daily views than cable
TV 2006
number two the first tweet the first
tweet was written by co-founder Jack
Dorsey on March 21st 2006 and it simply
read just setting up my Twitter we've
travelled from 1971 to 2006 many of the
events we've covered have changed the
way society interacts communicates and
does business these events were the very
first moments in some of the
fastest-growing and largest spheres of
influence ever seen by men so what is
number one well we'll take a quick break
and we'll be back after this so this
next event is number one not because of
its date or its significance but because
of its relevance to the modern internet
number one the world's first internet
meme it goes without saying that most
traditional internet memes have had
their day and more often than not
they're just pretty annoying but the
first meme was actually quite
interesting and it really depends on how
you look at it to answer this question
the very first meme could be recognized
as this a smiley face it was posted on
the 19th of September 1982 by Scott
Fahlman
during Scott's time at Carnegie Mellon
University he noticed that there was no
way of expressing human emotion during
text-based forum conversations between
computers at times jokes would often be
taken the wrong way and lengthy flame
wars were common Scott came up with the
elegant solution of a smiley face the
smiley face soon caught on and quickly
spread to other universities we were
being silly late at night we were
sending these things around messages and
I proposed this thing and I thought it
was just another silly message that I
sent you know I didn't keep a copy of it
and I noticed about a week later that
people are starting to use it around
Carnegie Mellon a couple of weeks later
that we got a message back from some
colleagues on the west coast of the US
and they were using it too now and they
were starting to make these long lists
you know of many different emoticons
I only claimed responsibility for the
the colon - and the parentheses a smiley
face in the frowny face with the nose so
some of you out there would not be
satisfied with this definition of meme
so let's look at the first meme that is
recognizable as a me
in the forum as we know it today this
will be the meme simply known as the
dancing baby thus first let loose on the
22nd of October 1996 the dancing baby
originated as a collection of
experimental testing data files as a
product sample for the then
groundbreaking 3d character animation
software called character studio it was
the first truly viral meme as we know it
today it found its way into hit shows
like Ally McBeal
third Rock from the Sun and The Simpsons
and many will still recognize it
immediately today so there you go
that is literally how many of the
aspects of the Internet that you're used
to seeing each and every day started out
if you would like to know how the
internet itself started please check out
part 2 of the greatest story ever told
on this channel it hasn't gotten many
views so far so I'm actually thinking of
remaking it and splitting it into a
series and smaller chunks anyway thanks
for choosing to watch my video and as
usual don't forget to rate comment and
subscribe I'll see you again soon for
the next one thanks guys
cold skipper are you thinking